salut confiné d'ici et d'ailleurs c'est
le nom du nouveau rendez vous que vous
offre la première en plein confinement
d'ailleurs cette émission est tournée
depuis mon sable aujourd'hui je vous
emmène à la rencontre d'une personnalité
il est dj il al'habitude de mixer un peu
partout dans le monde
on voulait savoir comment ils vivaient
cette période particulière de
confinement aujourd'hui rencontre avec
dj killers
c'est jimmy bienvenus
[Musique]
salut dj killer salut ça va et toi
comment tu vis ce confinement justement
rappelé l'enjeu parler de toi en disant
que tu étais tout temps dans un avion
tout le temps à mixer à droite à gauche
j'imagine que cette période de
confinement doit être particulièrement
dur ben on va dire oui et non parce que
bon il faut être adulte de pandémie
d'entrée très grave n'ait je le vis bien
parce que mine de rien ce matin j'ai
rarement eu le temps depuis des années
peut poser autant de temps non j'ai pas
le côté positif me dire que la vie
continue et il faut faire avec mais ça
permet de vous reposer de de me
concentrer les scion sûrement aussi de
combien de l'alimenter correctement
presque un peu chez moi et ma femme de
mon chien les proches en deuil ce sport
aussi à la maison le cuisiner quand on
est dj c'est un peu compliqué de faire
du télétravail
est-ce que tu arrive quand même à bosser
un peu chez pas sur des productions
ben oui sur les productions wii avec
l'équipe on travaille sur des beats à
distance on essaie de proposer des
choses compliquées
c'est un peu compliqué mais j'essaie de
travailler avec certains collaborateurs
dont des profs de sport et le d'associer
sur des nations des ventes sont fondées
des mixtapes un peu pour l'enfant
spécialisés avec leurs thématiques donc
on essaie de travailler sur son ensemble
à distance bon voilà ça permet de
m'occuper aussi à côté de mes petites
activités nautiques est bon on a vu
justement fleuret en pas mal
d'initiatives et tu parlais de sport
effectivement beaucoup de coachs
sportifs proposent des cours en live sur
les réseaux sociaux donc ça c'est super
c'est une belle initiative que ça permet
de but
j'ai dans cette période de confinement
de se changer les idées et puis de se
maintenir en forme
il ya des dj aussi qu'ils ont décidé de
jouer le jeu d'amener quelque chose à
ces personnes qui sont confinés qui
s'ennuient peut-être un petit peu en
mixant en faisant des sessions de mythes
son live sur les réseaux sociaux
ben on est on est plusieurs à cette
pratique
notre métier c'est avant tout leur
mouvement ça permet aux gens à la
bastille finances ont décompressé laisse
pas qu'il soit résolu leurs problèmes et
ces jours ci c'est une période difficile
et on si on peut tous les titres les
acteurs du milieu que ce soit restitué
existe y en a compté quelque chose pour
que le quotidien de toutes ces personnes
soient moins compliqué à vivre furent
dellape offrir des mixtes est possible
gratuitement sur son trône
je les fais déjà trois fois j'ai envie
d'un mix de radio 10 avec deux danseurs
un peu y en a plein qui font ce site
initiative et j'encourage tous mes
confrères a continué parce que grâce à
saab
nous ça nous occupe et ça permet à tous
ceux qui sont conduits demande d'avoir
un petit peu efficace dans les oreilles
est-ce qu'on peut annoncer des choses
que qui lancera une fois tout sous
s'avancera entrer dans le bon sens mais
sur l'épreuve avec des artistes
caribéens entière et puis en matière de
deux soirées ben je profite de cette
période pour me renouveler musicalement
continué à presser à travailler sur
d'autres choses et puis j'espère
toujours satisfaire ceux qui me suivent
depuis des années je profite pour les
remercier et je pense qu'après le
confinement que ce soit moi mais outre
mon frère on peut essayer de faire du
mieux qu'on peut en tout cas pour ma
part du travail dur travail sur d'autres
projets a aussi qui n'ont rien à voir la
musique
donc j'espère que tout ça fera plaisir à
tous ceux qui me donne la force et qui
me suivent de façon générale depuis des
années bon ok je te préviens dj killer
va falloir nous faire une grosse grosse
grosse soirée après ce confinement où on
va tous se retrouver histoire de faire
la fête après cette période difficile
bien évidemment enfin on va attendre
encore un peu puisque on est on est
encore loin d'être sortie tout ça mais
mais justement
grâce à ses conseils précieux j'espère
que tout le monde et surtout les jeunes
les écouterons et bas resteront à la
maison resteront confinées le temps que
ça se passe c'est important
ses portraits et moi si jamais ça ne
devrait pas céder à tout le monde vous
savez on va respecter les consignes de
confinement plus vite on pourra
recommencer à sortir de chez nous et
vaquer à nos occupations quotidiennes
soyez conscient sans respecter si le
personnel médical qui au quotidien se
bat auquel de l'envié aussi pour soigner
des personnes affectées % avec des
personnes malades ils le font pas de
gaîté de coeur c'est très dur pour eux
de voir des gens partir comme ça du jour
au lendemain
donc respectons ces personnes là qui se
mouille pour nos titres avec mon nom en
restant chez essayons tous de voir le
côté positif
au lieu de se dire ah non je restais
chez moi c'est pas une prison mais on le
fait pour lequel la planète
c'est ce qu'il faut retenir ensuite une
impasse technique merci beaucoup dj
killer ans pour ce petit moment avec toi
et puis ce message super positif
on espère autant revoir très bientôt
avec de nouveaux projets on a déjà hâte
merci en tout cas hockey pee wee
bon voilà je te remercie pour
l'initiative merci beaucoup dj killer
c'est merci à tous et dj qui nous
ambiance à chaque jour sur les réseaux
sociaux
voilà qu'on fini d'ici et d'ailleurs est
maintenant terminée on se retrouve très
vite sur la première
[Musique]